Nobody likes being trash-talked, but it's
especially unpleasant when you and your trash-talker
are both high profile celebrities.
Add in that we're essentially talking about
workplace disputes between directors and actors
and it becomes a multilayered personal and
professional attack.
Here are some directors who publicly dissed
their actors.
J.J.
Abrams on Daisy Ridley
It was a shock when Daisy Ridley, who starred
as Rey in Star Wars: The Force Awakens, told
Glamour UK that J.J.
Abrams called her out on her first day of
shooting, criticizing her performance as “wooden”
in front of cast and crew.
As for why Abrams may have been a little tactless
with his criticism?
It could be the enormous responsibility of
Disney's four billion dollar investment in
this franchise reboot resting on his shoulders.
Kevin Smith On Bruce Willis
No other director has gone out of his way
to trash an actor like Kevin Smith did with
Bruce Willis.
Smith's taken to podcasts, live stage shows,
and Twitter to call out Willis.
Smith's beef is this: while filming Cop Out,
Willis couldn't have cared less and went out
of his way to make the production difficult
for everyone.
"Why did you smack me?!"
On Marc Maron's WTF podcast, Smith said the
experience was "soul crushing.”
Michael Bay On Megan Fox
Michael Bay didn't turn on Megan Fox until
after she compared him to Hitler in a magazine
interview.
After that, Bay was free to not only fire
and replace Fox from the third Transformers
movie, but to tell GQ, "I'm sorry, Megan.
I'm sorry I made you work twelve hours.
Movies are not always warm and fuzzy."
They eventually reconciled, with Fox starring
as April O’Neil in Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles in 2014, which Bay produced.
Paul Schrader On Lindsay Lohan
Paul Schrader took a chance casting the troubled
Lindsay Lohan in The Canyons, a low-budget
erotic thriller.
At every opportunity, Lohan held up production
with insane demands and erratic behavior.
She clashed with co-star James Deen and even
forced Schrader to strip naked in front of
the crew because she had to do the same thing
for a love scene.
In the end, Schrader wouldn't admit to regret
over her casting, but he did throw a jab over
whether he'd cast her in something else, musing,
"It doesn't involve a co-star.
She would be perfect for it."
Stephen Norrington On Sean Connery
The League of Extraordinary Gentlemen was
such a difficult production that it ended
the careers of both its director and its star.
Connery endlessly told the press what an idiot
he thought Norrington was, never acted again,
and Norrington vowed to never direct another
film.
And this was only his fourth movie, following
the massive success of his work on the original
Blade.
Vincent Gallo On Christina Ricci
After their time working together on the 1998
road movie Buffalo 66, director and star Vincent
Gallo called co-star Christina Ricci “ungrateful”
and accused her of being an alcoholic, or
that "she was on cough syrup the whole time.”
More than 15 years later, Ricci responded
when asked about Buffalo 66 on HuffPost Live:
"But, no I spent most of that movie trapped
in a car with a raving lunatic."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
feud you think is the nastiest.